direction tout de suite marioupol pour
vous faire vivre en direct cette
conférence de presse du maire de
marioupol on écoute
et il faut le dire très clairement
leur situation est très difficile car
ils sont en infériorité numérique et
c'est donc très difficile
il faut savoir que si on dit qu'ils sont
faits d'acier l'acier a aussi un point
de rupture mais il résiste à marioupol
mario pas le reste l'ukrainienne
c'est également difficile à cause de la
situation humanitaire qui est
catastrophique
créé par les envahisseurs russes et
leurs collaborateurs
du bloc de l'opposition
alors qu'ils ont décrit des
infrastructures essentielles aînés a
plus d'eau plus d'électricité
en plus de cela il ya la propagande
russe
les habitants de marioupol n'ont accès à
aucune information
il ya eu des tentatives d'évacuation
mais les envahisseurs n'ont voulu
laisser sortir personnes
fragiles ils ont tiré
volontairement
détruit tous les bus que nous
souhaitions utilisée pour l'évacuation
en dix jours
ils ont réduit toutes ses tentatives à
néant
l'ennemi à contrecarrer tous nos efforts
les habitants ont cherché de à a quitté
la ville
mais ils n'ont pu ce rôle que vers le
premier checkpoint et qui portait la
bannière russe
nous avons reçu l'ordre de permettre le
passage de tout habitant de mario pole
mais ils ont dû faire demi tour
on à dire les russes ont dit ensuite
qu'il avait été abandonné
et alors que le monde entier demande et
une évacuation
on a cherché à assurer l'évacuation avec
des véhicules privés
et les troupes ennemies ont cherché un
os ouvert des points d'évacuation pour
aller vers berdier en ski vers à partir
de quoi elle devait ensuite continué
environ cent cinquante mille personnes
ont pu quitter mario paul pour se rendre
dans d'autres territoire ukrainien
il y à encore plus de cent mille
personnes à marioupol
il ya aussi des personnes en banlieue
proche de marioupol soit soixante mille
personnes supplémentaires donc nous
appelons encore tous les jours tous les
matins elle la communauté internationale
à s'unir pour libérer mario paul pour
évacuer
les personnes innocentes civile de mario
paul
marion parole tiendra autant que notre
pays tiendra
les
négociations
ont
permis d'avancer sur la question
humanitaire le résultat de ces
négociations
c'est qu'en fait la fédération de russie
ne cherche pas à soutenir toute mission
internationale et on s'est très
clairement pourquoi soit
ils attaquent les missions humanitaires
soient des attaques tout type de mission
qui cherchent à intervenir
il faut venir dans la ville pour se
rendre compte des atrocités causés par
les troupes russes qui ont détruit des
hôpitaux des 10 n
2 de cadavres peuvent se retrouver dans
dans la rue dès
des hôpitaux ont été incendiés
un génocide qui est commis par les
russes
c'est une guerre qui a été déclarée par
un criminel de guerre poutine contre
notre société notre nation
est la seule chose qu'il a réussi à
faire c'est de détruire la ville de
mario paul
il n'y a plus de son
très bien nous entendons à nouveau
le son est à nouveau coupée
nous entendons encore de nouvelles
tragiques de mario paul
comme nous avons pu l'entendre il n'y
aura pas d'évacuation humanitaire
aujourd'hui depuis mario paul
avez vous d'autres questions
le sont une nouvelle fois été perdu nous
allons chercher à nous reconnecter
le vice premier ministre a déclaré qu'il
n'y aurait pas
d'évacuation aujourd'hui
comme le maire de mario pas la plus nous
dire aujourd'hui
il sera impossible pour les habitants de
quitter mario paul en véhicule privé
vous donne la parole aux journalistes
avez vous des preuves qui montrent que
les forces russes ont
jeté des agents chimiques sur mario paul
concernant les crimes de guerre il ya eu
des preuves à mario paul la première
fois c'était le 9 mars lorsque les les
avions russes ont jeté des bombes sur la
maternité de mario paul ou une femme
était en train d'accoucher puis le 16
mars un mario paul un autre avion russe
a jeté de bombes
sur le théâtre de mario paul à tout cela
était documenté nous avons également
documenté
les
les attaques sur les immeubles
résidentiels qui sont impossibles à à
reconstruire
nous avons des enregistrements vidéo des
photos
qui ont été récoltés par
les autorités de notre pays s'il s'agit
de crimes de guerre avant-hier les
forces russes ont cherché à
faire une attaque chimique sur notre
ville
a
jeté un agent chimique sur nos
défenseurs
dans les abords de mario paul
des personnes ont pu ressentir un goût
sucré dans leur bouche
ce qui
est en fait un indice
est alors les habitants d abord de mario
paul ont commencé à quitter la zone
parce qu'ils ont senti le danger
il est impossible de
retrouver des preuves de cela
mais les troupes ennemies et leurs
intermédiaires de donetsk
ont montré qu'ils avaient la volonté
d'utiliser les agents chimiques parce
qu'il n'arrive pas à l'emporter face à
notre défenseur de la ville
avant cela il y avait déjà des
informations qui montrait que certains
laboratoires chimique est dans la ville
développer des agents ou des armes
chimiques
et nous savions qu'ils allaient lancer
cette attaque et malheureusement c'est
ce qu'il s'est passé
y at-il eu des crématoires mobile
le 1er avril
nous avons constaté
plus de 5000 pertes civiles
qui sont morts suite aux pilonnages de
l'aviation ennemie
depuis le 21 mars nous n'avons pas pu
constater les pertes parce que les
troupes russes ont gagné de la
profondeur dans la ville
[Musique]
et des milliers de personnes sont encore
morte par la suite d'après nos
estimations plus de vingt mille
personnes ont été tuées par les troupes
ennemies de la fédération de russie
des agents russes ont bombardé la ville
depuis le 9 mars sans discontinuer
il cherche aujourd'hui à cacher les
preuves de cette attaque
nous
nous avons pu voir sur youtube que ils
disent que les cadavres sont serait soit
disant partis d'eux-mêmes en fait
en réalité
nos renseignements
ont montré qu'il ya eu des crématoires
qui sont arrivés dans la ville et qui se
prépare à éliminer les preuves des
crimes de guerre commis par la
fédération de russie une dernière
question
combien de civils sont morts à mario sol
[Musique]
y
at-il eu des crimes de guerre
ce qu'il s'est passé à mario paul
le fait que 90% des infrastructures ont
été éliminés par la fédération de russie
des embardées hôpitaux des abris
bombarder les civils tués 21 mille
personnes voire plus ont été tuées à
marioupol voilà le nombre de pertes
liées aux pilonnages russe nous pensons
que ce sont des crimes d'hier c'est un
génocide de la nation ukrainienne par la
fédération de russie dans notre ville et
dans notre pays je vous remercie une
dernière question en tant que mère de
mario paul il y a deux mois vous viviez
une vie normale est aujourd'hui
votre ville s'enfonce dans la ruine et
le désespoir que ressentez vous
notre ville est de déterminer
nous allons résister aux russes
la ville
ne s'est pas rendue
nous reconstruire nous avons construit
une ville avec des hôpitaux des des
écoles
notre ville était prospère elle devenait
européenne cité une ville tournée vers
l'avenir
de nombreuses personnes
se sont engagés pour que cela devienne
possible n'y a pas eu de changements
positifs à donetsk
ils ont détruit notre ville notre vie
qui devait être
dans une renaissance
et moi j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
pour que
cela arrive mais sachez que notre ville
restera ukrainienne